[Musik]
der wallach lucky ist patient im
tierspital zürich
sein besitzer hatte in den letzten
wochen beim reiten ein eigenartiges
lächeln bemerkt
sogar gratis
egal ob überhaupt
[Musik]
das tierspital zürich feiert seinen
fünfzigsten geburtstag
900 angestellt und jährlich 20.000
patienten die nicht sagen können was ihm
fehlt
stimmt es dass man den zustand einer
gesellschaft an ihrem umgang mit tieren
erkennt
[Musik]
sind millionen ausgaben für die
gesundheit der tiere ein ausdruck von
dekadenz wird hier die vermenschlichung
von tieren auf die spitze getrieben
oder zeigen wir gerade im umgang mit
wehrlosen mitgeschöpfen ob uns werte wie
empathie und nächstenliebe wirklich
wichtig sind
[Musik]
konsultation in einer welt die weit mehr
mit uns menschen zu tun hat als wir
denken
[Musik]
waschen oder galoppieren
das gut hörbare lächeln von lucky
tochter erst auf wenn er sich anstrengt
und
berlin
also es ist jetzt wichtig dass michael
kempter
slowenisch oder wie im uhr schlafen wenn
das gibt ein anderer ursachen oder
fusion ist groß und bei ihm ist es jetzt
nötig wenn er dies rufe und das zentrum
will immer dann wenn er mit dem inneren
vorführer hund doch testen
oder wenn sie sich durch machten
das ist ganz normal
vor einigen tagen brach leo der
spanische wind und plötzlich zusammen
sein herz streckte
kardiologen untersuchen leos herz mit
einem speziellen ultraschall gerät
langsam nähert für kunden und das
passiert weil das wir haben wie ein
block ins herz und das macht er sehr
sehr langsam
leon nimmt seltsame gerüche war hörte
eigenartige geräusche und zieht
unbekannte menschen die irgendetwas mit
dem vorhaben
[Musik]
leo ist hört der beruhigungsmittel
verängstigt heute bekommt der rüde einen
herzschrittmacher
toni klaus ist abteilungsleiter der
kardiologie er wird den seltenen
eingriff durchführen
[Musik]
also man der schritt sicher
die realität ist extrem wichtig wenn
irgendwas kontaminiert ist bringen sie
die bakterien - und wenn man
schlussendlich news die sonne so eine
stromkabel wieder aus dem herzlosen
ethisch hochtouren
das heißt das wäre absolut
kreuzkontamination gehen
die wirkung der narkose setzten jetzt
beginnt die heikelste phase für leos
geschwächtes herz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das fohlen hat noch kein lagen der ring
war der geburt vergessen dass junge
stolperte sozusagen ins leben
und darum als sehr
miete so starre china hat mir das rennen
therapie und gott um einen krieg schon
wieder viel besser aber es muss die
frage zum soll auch
ein geburtsfehler die strecke szenen der
vorderbeine waren nicht
zusammengewachsen
[Musik]
länder klein will tierärztin werden das
letzte jahr ihres studiums absolviert
sie am tierspital
zehn semester lang hat sie theorie
gebüffelt die wichtigste lektion lernt
sie hier
das andere
erstaunlich dass gross innerhalb des
ortes sie könnte auf zu schlagen
und wieder ich 17 war sehr schwierig
sind
und jetzt hat man also von einjährige
unter beruf anstreben das ist besser zu
hause
und es ist wirklich ein schwieriger
start haben ist nicht behinderung oft
vor dass voll eingerichtete
forderungskauf
29 jährige machte zuerst eine
kaufmännische liegen für das studium der
veterinärmedizin entschied sich erst
später
ja also ich denke
für sie da macht es schon einfach weil
mit ihr derart herzig findet und lernt
aber
es gibt ja viele sachen oder ein bogen
gewinnen und beine nicht so schön aber
so kratz emissions- die auf ähnlich
schon sehr aktiv
linker kleiner zählt unter den
studierenden sei es ein viel
diskutiertes thema wo die richtige
balance zwischen emotionaler nähe und
professioneller distanzen an
die colonia ist abgemagert und gibt viel
weniger milch als früher
professor uli braun ist direktor des
departements für nutztiere er
beschäftigt sich seit bald 30 jahren mit
kühen
die hohe strafe wäre ein fiasko
bei die vene
macht wenig staub
und die vene laufen oder
herz- oder die müsse erklären sich
auch selber machen nichts der besitzer
glaubt seine crew habe ein scharfes
metallstück verschluckt das hier nun
probleme machen
wenn der strom per punkte jahren
und nachher den netz mache
die arthur liebfrauen vermutet ein
herzproblem
der maßstab ob das stimmt oder ob sie in
schmerz zeigt
unzählige studierende haben bei ihm
gelernt wie man einen patienten
untersucht der nicht sagen kann es
wehtut und dafür große reiz
franken
[Musik]
versuche das merkt fühle sie
war hättest dir
warum ich dass die krank gefühlt dass
dir wir versuchen ihnen zu ersetzen sind
er grundlegende sachen wo mich sehr
beschäftigt und erfreue mich
befriedigend
[Musik]
kurze zeit kostet und sie hat damit
derzeit nährstoffe als zeichen des märz
reduziert reduziert reduzierte
bauer ernst menzi ist ratlos wie soll es
mit seiner ronja weitergehen das herz
unterschied und das wort und spezialist
nur herz macht oder rahm herz kann ich
das radikal vor aber der rest
ultraschall machen selber
und denn nur um reine telefonieren
und kunst
[Musik]
lucky hat einen termin in der
sportmedizin verkehr de
[Musik]
die ärztin nina wandern führt ein
endoskop in seinen rachen ring
während sich lucky anstrengt filme die
tierärztinnen seinen kehlkopf
deutlich zu sehen jedes mal wenn er
einatmet kollabiert das rechte stimmband
und verengt die luftröhre
[Musik]
video bilder aus dem innern des tieres
ein laufband verkehr de
die ärzte sagen der wissenschaftliche
ehrgeiz und die neugier des menschen
dürfe nie zum selbstzweck werden alles
müsse dazu dienen dass der patient
gesund werde
ich glaube das ist das was man werk oder
ich meine das erklärt schon der kohle
macht die studie kollabiert und sie den
arm cortex tm rein und wenn er dann
bei der ausatmung dann kann es wieder
denn ist also gegen den eindruck kann es
irgendwie wieder deponieren natürlich
während ein harter
[Musik]
wind und leo schläft tief
die operation wird durch diesen kleinen
schnitt gemacht
toni klaus führt ein kabel durch die
halsvene direkt ins herz des hundes
der kardiologe weiß dass er hier etwas
tut das bei vielen menschen
unverständnis und kopfschütteln auslöst
so unrecht findet er mache jemand für
dreieinhalbtausend fährten ferien um
sich etwas gutes zu tun sei das völlig
normal schenke jemand für das gleiche
geld einem geliebten tier ein neues
leben werde dies häufig als dekadent
verurteilt aber das noch trotzdem mache
trotzdem druck soziale druck die sind
wahnsinnig kyte werden dann wieder
normal ischen noch im rennen und
neo hat die operation gut überstanden
der schrittmacher funktioniert
einwandfrei
wenn du bis nico grund ist der absolute
dazu die katastrophe und den skoda grund
ist die extrem extrem motivierend ist
alles gut
strom gerade
was das praktisch immer gut ich aber
mehr weiß was mir das geht das bis li
dies die nervosität schon aber ansonsten
großartigen auch der mensch und seine im
harz blendend sie motivieren
auf der intensivstation wacht leo
langsam wieder auf
er hat nicht etwas schmerzen im rausch
der medikamente versteht er schlicht die
welt nicht mehr
[Musik]
die röntgenaufnahme von colonia zeigt
keinen fremdkörper in ihrem magen
colin schwarzwald hat vor jahren bei
professor li braun studiert heute ist er
selbst professor und herzspezialist am
tierspital
er macht den ultraschall untersucht von
runners herz um herauszufinden warum
sich das blut in ihre halsvene staudt
richtig löst aber nicht im land richtig
zurückfließt als 200 richtig politik und
in dem fall ist es so dass die
heizkörper so dick ist das das blog gar
nicht richtig durchfließen kann
ein schlechter befund oli brown
informierten bauer
tierspital
grüezi herr menzi
güterverkehr
bag tonia
krankheit ist herzkrank und
zwei
hochgradige
bakterielle herzklappen in sündig also
dass ihr könnt mir mühe machen mut
machen es gibt ja bekanntlich oder
so hat mir wirklich leid ihnen gern prof
alles gute
weiß nicht
das macht mir jedes mal in ihm
assistierte
cologna muss eingeschläfert werden die
letzten stunden verbringt sie im
krankenzimmer der nutzte
linda klein assistiert als wallach lucky
und das messer kommt oder besser gesagt
unter den laser professor
anton fürst der direktor der pferde
abteilung entfernt teile des gelähmten
stimmen
spezielle gruppen
ja
lucky wird nie mehr schön wie dafür
wieder frei atmen kann
insgesamt wird stimmen waren entfernte
oder was ist stimmt eschen die rechte
leichte stimmband das ist linke
stimmband wo fehlt mit bestimmter rom
entfernt
für linda klein ein spannender einsatz
sie ist begeisterte reiterin und hat
sich schon während ihres studiums auf
pferde medizin spezialisiert
in wenigen stunden wird sie lucky wieder
seinem besitzer übergeben kann
isabella kienholz muss ihren leo nach
der operation noch schonen
sechs jahren regelmäßig
dass man sich merkt voran dass es nicht
zu überschreiten das ist wichtig und
setzt sich kaum west klage hätte macht
richtige
wo sollen die grenzen der modernen
medizin liegen und wer entscheidet wie
weit die behandlung von tieren gehen
darf isabella kienholz hat sich diese
frage gar nicht gestellt sie wollte
einfach das beste für ihren lehrer
also das herz eröffnen wir bei uns immer
so dass der dass wir so schneiden wieder
blutfluss im herz läuft und hier fällt
bereits auf das wirklich fast die
gesamte klasse der anfangs teil der
rechten herzkammer durch eine fesche
blumenkohl artige buchung angefüllt ist
das kranke herz von colonia in der
pathologie findet ihr ende doch noch
einen sinn angehende tierärztinnen
lernen eine heimtückische krankheit
kennen
vor über 30 jahren stand uli braun wie
diese jungen frauen am seziertisch heute
schlägt sein herz noch immer für den
beruf des tierarztes
begeisterungsfähigkeit für den beruf
fürs tier für alles war mit dem sender
handelt oder um ein buch das ich denke
tierliebe egal wer regiert das man
behandeln muss für kreatur großes gefühl
haben oder auch wenn
es nun schwierig wenn es ist schwierig
wenn es jetzt nicht mein buch das
mitgefühl für das mietgeschäft und ihr
glaubt
ja das ist ganze ist ein ziel oder
[Applaus]
die bandagen werden immer kürzer das
fohlen ohne namen immer besser
[Musik]
in den letzten wochen hat länder klein
ihren patienten mit viel geduld das
laufen beigebracht
das fohlen ist ihr ans herz gewachsen
max der iran könne wenn sie doch ein hai
auf ihre weiter
immer gesellschaft ihren bewegungsdrang
hand
wahre menschlichkeit zeigt sich im
umgang mit den schwächsten
tiere sind patienten ohne stimme umso
größer ist die verantwortung des
menschen
denn der zustand einer gesellschaft
erkennt man an ihrem umgang mit den
tieren
[Musik]